know what we're talking about I think
it's important to look at the traffic
that we see in terms of this trade in
human beings across the Mediterranean
because what we see is that a lot of
people coming are economic migrants but
they are people who are paying criminal
gangs paying criminals to transport them
across Africa people these criminals are
then pushing them into vessels which
they know very often are not seaworthy
where people's lives will be put at risk
and of course we as the United Kingdom
are participating in the search and
rescue operation to make sure that
people are not dying at sea but we need
to deal with these criminal gangs we
need to deal with this terrible kellers
trade in human beings and partly that is
about the expertise that can help to
interdict the this the criminals and
deal with them in our National Crime
Agency is working with Europol we're
offering that expertise as well but also
I think it's important that the
criminals aren't able simply to say to
people if you pay us money we are going
to risk your put your lives at risk but
don't worry you will get to Europe and
that's why it's important that people
picked up in the Mediterranean can be
taken back to Africa but do you agree if
you use that the term forcibly removed
that it does imply that these people
who've endured all manner of
difficulties actually trying to get to
some safety that you're then going to
put them further into difficulties in
terms of forcibly returning them to
their countries countries that they're
fleeing from well first of all I don't
think that's a phrase that I myself have
used but what I did say was that the
high representative the European high
representative federica mogherini had
said that no effectively that nobody
should be returned maybe should returned
against their will and therefore
effectively that Europe should accept
anybody who wishes to come to Europe and
I think as I say what we're seeing lying
behind a lot of these people come in
trying to come to Europe is this
terrible trade in human beings these are
there are criminals who are making money
making a profit out of people's
aspirations and doing so in a way where
they know these
people's lives will be put at risk I
think that is a terrible trade I think
we need to deal with that and I think we
need to ensure that the criminals are
not able to fly this business and nan-oh